on this saturday night state of
emergency
a massive earthquake rocks haiti causing
death and destruction in the caribbean
country already reeling from a
humanitarian crisis
closing in on kabul the taliban takeover
of afghanistan is now within striking
distance of the country's capital on
your marks political leaders get set to
hit the campaign trail with an election
call expected sunday plus what's the
secret to athletic success the one thing
that has kept me like sane throughout
this whole process is my love for
knitting and
[Music]
crochet global national with robin gill
reporting tonight jeff semple
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight in haiti thousands
of people are feared dead after that
country was hit by a powerful earthquake
the 7.2 magnitude quake struck this
morning about 125 kilometers west of the
capital puerto process
today's earthquake was even larger and
more shallow than the devastating quake
that rocked the caribbean country 11
years ago killing around a quarter of a
million people
the first images are just beginning to
emerge from the aftermath hundreds are
already confirmed dead but that number
is expected to rise in the coming hours
the u.s geological survey has issued a
red alert warning of a high number of
expected casualties as aid groups now
scramble to assess the damage we're now
joined by a member of one of those eight
organizations cara buck is the acting
country director with mercy corps in
haiti and she joins us now from the
capital port-au-prince cara thank you
for joining us so what is the latest
that you're hearing about the extent of
the damage on the ground
absolutely and thanks so much for having
me you know um neep which is you know
the the epicenter is is quite rural with
with high rates of of poverty and hunger
um from this morning phone internet um
access community communications have
been very limited um but we are hearing
from from our team on the ground we have
a team of 19 on the ground in neat which
is the epicenter
um you know that that there's reported
collapses um collapsing homes buildings
and potential road blockages access
accessing neep
um and and everyone is is you know
worried about the family and and worried
about those that may have been injured
and what can you tell us about the areas
that were worst hit you know before the
quake how populated were they any
hospitals nearby
sure so certainly you know kind of as i
mentioned it's it's a rather rural
area neap and surrounding areas with
with poverty hunger
food insecurity etc and we know of
course the country's still recovering
from the devastating earthquake back in
2010 plus the pandemic food insecurity
the recent assassination of the haitian
president so to what extent kara is the
country able to respond to this latest
disaster i think any any country under
similar conditions would uh you know
be it would be difficult for them to
respond and we're seeing nothing
different in haiti so you know
absolutely resources are are stretched
um but but we're trying to pull together
and do what we can to ensure people have
what they need
and any message for the international
community at this point
certainly i mean you know
it's it's somewhat of a of a shame or
unfortunate that it takes something like
it like an earthquake to to to um ensure
the spotlight is is on haiti but um you
know the the the people here the team
are resilient and and like i said we're
gonna do everything we can to to make
sure people have what they need um and
and see them through this this
incident
that's kara buck with mercy corps in
port-au-prince haiti stay safe thanks
cara
thank you so much
canada is home to nearly 200 000 haitian
canadians and many tonight are left
feeling helpless unable to reach their
relatives amid news of the devastation
dan spector has their story
on a sunny saturday morning haiti was
jolted awake and into scenes of pure
horror a 7.2 magnitude earthquake hit
the south of the country at about 8 30
a.m turning many buildings to rubble and
sending people running into the streets
out of fear their homes could collapse
haiti was still recovering from the
powerful earthquake that struck the
caribbean nation in twenty ten this one
was even stronger it's like unbelievable
for us again
marjorie vilfrash runs montreal's maison
daisy a community center serving the
tens of thousands of haitian expats who
live in the city we know that the
hospitals are full
and there is no help she says the area
of haiti hardest hit by saturday's quake
is remote it's a very isolated region
with no roads to go there
so how the how the help will get there
by playing by boat we don't know it was
a nightmare leaving once again france
benjamin is a member of quebec's
national assembly and was born in haiti
he's been hearing from montrealers who
have not been able to reach their loved
ones living near the earthquake's
epicenter it is a stressful situation
for them of course
they say the
100 plus everyone is trying to find out
more says jean nouma gudu who runs a
haitian newspaper in montreal he's
spoken to dozens of montrealers trying
to find out if friends and family
members are okay we're going to need
the solidarity and the help of the old
canadian society benjamin says a meeting
is being planned with montreal haitian
leaders to discuss what can be done to
help premier lego on twitter sent his
thoughts to his province's haitian
population mayor valerie plant says her
heart is with haiti and montreal's
haitian community the largest in canada
and that the city will help finance
relief efforts we feel useless here you
know what can we do for now montreal
haitians can only hope and pray as many
expect the news will get worse in the
coming days dan specter global news
montreal
turning now to the developing situation
in afghanistan the taliban is rapidly
advancing across large parts of the
country the insurgents have captured
much of the northwest and southern
afghanistan and they now control about
two-thirds of the country in just the
last 24 hours the taliban has reportedly
taken four more provincial capitals
including masari sharif leaving kabul as
the last major city under the western
allied government's control
for at least for now the militants are
now just 70 kilometers outside of the
capital like canada the united states is
working to get its personnel out of
kabul and president biden just announced
he's sending 1 000 additional troops to
help with that mission as jennifer
johnson explains human rights groups
fear the country is on the brink of a
major humanitarian crisis
as the world watches in shock taliban
soldiers are taking control of
afghanistan with lightning speed
the militants are adding to their ranks
freeing taliban prisoners in several
cities aid workers are warning of a
humanitarian crisis as afghans flee to
kabul others are packing the airport
desperate to get out millions of women
fear what will happen to them under
oppressive taliban rule i'm afraid of
being killed like it's i'm like totally
sure that i will not survive here
the militants are notorious for violence
against women raping and torturing those
who won't live by their strict religious
rules many believe they will be in
prison in their homes again stripped of
all rights education or worse women are
scared they're not even going outside
because you might go outside and risk
your life because
you're not wearing the appropriate
clothing in the eyes of the taliban
thousands of desperate afghans are also
crowding the border of pakistan begging
to be let in
abandoned by the u.s military and its
allies some afghan soldiers are being
executed others are laying down their
arms left behind u.s military equipment
seized by the taliban we are always
worried about u.s equipment that could
fall into an adversary's hands five
thousand members of the u.s military are
rushing to kabul temporarily to evacuate
embassy staff president joe biden left
washington for camp david this weekend
staying publicly silent about the crisis
while being briefed by national security
and military leaders
but others are speaking out including
soldiers who fought to protect
afghanistan from extremists
i'm really upset why did we spend
the past decade there what was the
purpose what was the goal for now
president biden is sticking to his
decision to withdraw u.s troops by the
end of the month believing the war had
gone on too long
and cost too many american lives
but he is under increasing pressure to
do something before it's too late
jennifer johnson global news washington
back here at home prime minister justin
trudeau will set the stage for the
country's 44th general election tomorrow
when he asks the governor general to
dissolve parliament election day is
expected to be september the 20th
heading to the polls in a pandemic will
be a different experience for voters our
chief political correspondent david
aiken joins us now with more on what to
expect david
well the objective for the incumbent
liberals is pretty obvious jeff it's
majority or bust a minority government
will not be good enough for justin
trudeau's liberals and in fact if that's
what happens at the end of this campaign
you can expect some liberals may start
to talk about a leadership change
now the polls for the last year have
been consistent liberals have always
been leading but their lead as they
start this campaign is not quite big
enough to guarantee that majority so
this campaign will matter for
conservative leader aaron o'toole
anything less than forming a minority
government will be seen as a failure and
remember in 2019 andrew shears
conservatives won the popular vote and
improved their party standing by about
20 seats and yet shear lost his job
o'toole has probably the most difficult
task ahead of any leader
the ndp and jugg meet sang look set to
move from fourth place in the house of
commons to third place a bigger caucus
in a minority government where they hold
the balance of power that is the ndp
sweet spot and for that reason singh's
campaign just might be the one to watch
as for the black quebecois and its
leader ethnois blache the bq have 32
seats now and the poll suggests they
could finish the campaign with about the
same and if they do that the block just
might block that liberal majority
as for the greens and leader anime paul
well the party is in complete disarray
and it might count itself lucky if it
holds on to just elizabeth may seat on
vancouver island
now this pandemic election will also be
a very different one for voters fewer
mass rallies less likelihood a candidate
will knock on your door as campaigns
will rely much more heavily on
personalized digital media for voter
outreach
and how we vote will likely be very
different this time elections canada
believes that as many as 5 million
canadians will vote by mail this time
that compares to just 50 000 who voted
by mail in 2019 and since each one of
those mail-in ballots has to be open by
hand and has to be counted by hand
unlike the u.s there's no machines
involved while elections canada is
warning it might be a few days after
election day before we get the final
result and know what our next parliament
looks like jeff
david aiken in ottawa thanks david
we're getting a clearer picture tonight
of the devastation from those raging
wildfires tearing through bc's interior
this is the community of monty lake
where residents are returning to find
their homes reduced to ash wiped out
after being overrun by the massive white
rock lake wildfire burning near vernon
bc officials are warning tourists to
avoid traveling to the popular okanagan
region this weekend with more evacuation
orders likely
if you are thinking of visiting there
don't we want to ensure that people in
these communities will be able to
evacuate if necessary
access the supports they need as well as
the safety of our firefighters on the
ground
thousands of people have already been
ordered to leave their homes and the
situation is expected to spiral with
powerful winds clocking 60 kilometers an
hour forecast to arrive tomorrow adding
more fuel to the fires tonight 271
wildfires are burning across bc 60 of
those began just this week at the height
of another searing heat wave
those wildfires have been fueled in part
by scorching temperatures and new data
shows why july was the hottest month
ever recorded
according to the national oceanic and
atmospheric administration in the u.s
the combined land and ocean surface
temperature was almost a degree above
the 20th century average at 15.8 degrees
that makes it the highest temperature
ever recorded in the world since records
began
142 years ago
still ahead canada's vaccine passport
plans who will need them and how will
they work
[Music]
in montreal thousands gathered to
protest the province's planned covit 19
passport quebec confirmed this week that
a certificate system will be implemented
in september the move would give only
fully vaccinated people access to
restaurants bars festivals and other
events organizers of today's protest
call it an unprecedented prejudice for
the population
and the federal government also
announced plans for a vaccine passport
system for travelers but there is still
plenty of confusion about how it will
work jamie morrocker has more
zach gerling says moving back to canada
from the british virgin islands was
chaos amid covid having the tests
and like hotel quarantines and the
quarantine timing and
all the different ways that people are
going around it's why the 28 year old
jet setter is excited about canada
announcing a federal covet 19 vaccine
passport if it makes it easier to get
around and
move
people safely and
easier i'm all for it but it may not be
easier for girling he was vaccinated
with astrazeneca which despite being an
approved covet-19 vaccine here may not
be recognized in other countries david
dole who was vaccinated with a mix of
moderna and pfizer faces a similar
problem there is no issue with mixing
vaccines as far as the science goes so
far and
yeah i think canada needs to clear that
up but ottawa hasn't offered any
assurances the passport will fix this
problem or even that foreign countries
will accept it i think this is a global
effort if it's going to be something
that's supposed to be recognized by all
countries still travel experts are
hopeful travelers all will have some
peace of mind that they'll know prior to
going to a country that this passport
will be accepted martin firestone runs a
travel insurance brokerage in toronto
and says there are also questions about
domestic use of the federal document the
ability to go to a sports attraction a
cinema or a restaurant and will it be
used for that that's the gray line
already some provinces including quebec
alberta saskatchewan and manitoba are
shutting down the idea of using the
federal passport locally ontario
meantime is asking ottawa to pick up the
pace with no hard rollout date revealed
other than early fall
hopefully this wouldn't be a permanent
thing it's just hopefully for the amount
of time while the global pandemic is
going on there's no word on how long
these vaccine passports would be in
effect for but we do know that they'll
likely be digital and common across all
provinces they will include the holder's
covet 19 vaccine history and will be
available to all canadian citizens
permanent residents and temporary
residents who are living here and fully
vaccinated jamie morocco global news
toronto
still ahead why the race appears to be
tightening ahead of tuesday's election
in nova scotia
welcome back as canadians get ready for
a federal election in nova scotia the
focus is still on the provincial vote
which takes place this tuesday so far in
canada every incumbent government that
has called an election during the
pandemic has won but will nova scotia
buck the trend alicia drouse reports
vote making sure that we rebound with a
stronger economy for the most part it's
been a calm campaign but that's not to
say it's been completely without
controversy just before the election was
called premier ian rankin publicly
announced that in the early 2000's he
had been charged twice with drinking and
driving and despite failing two
breathalyzers he claimed he was innocent
in the second case where the charges
were dropped due to a lack of evidence
the official campaign then got off to a
rocky start when a liberal party
candidate dropped out the first week
robin ingraham initially blamed mental
health reasons but in a follow-up post
on social media the former candidate for
dartmouth south said that was what the
party had told her to say instead she
says she was actually asked to leave the
party over boudoir photos posted online
so the public was asked to be forgiving
of ian rankin for his past encounters
with the law including a conviction
and here you have a situation where a
woman candidate
had not had any trouble with the law
while the liberals are polling in the
lead both the progressive conservatives
and ndp have been gaining ground with
each party having a clear focus
getting nova scotians access to health
care
that's what this campaign is all about a
vote for the ndp is a vote for permanent
rent control and a vote for permanent
rent control is a vote for the ndp i
think people are kind of gravitating
through those messages i don't see as
much of a clear message from the liberal
campaign while the liberals do have the
advantage of being an incumbent
government that successfully led nova
scotia through the covet 19 pandemic
liberal leader ian rankin can't take
full credit for that that was a lot of
mcneil that was only been ranking for a
short time in february rankin replaced
liberal leader stephen mcneill who
stepped down after leaving the party
since 2007 but in the end it all comes
down to ballots cast and voter turnout
has been on the decline with just over
53 percent of people voting in 2017. the
most important thing now is for the
parties to mobilize their vote and make
sure that people actually show up for
them
even after all the ballots are cast it
won't be long before nova scotians are
returning to the polls for a federal
election in september and while nova
scotia is currently just one of two
provinces with a liberal provincial
government even if that change is on
tuesday it likely won't have any impact
on the federal liberals who currently
hold the majority of seats in nova
scotia alicia droves global news halifax
and that is global national for this
saturday night i'm jeff semple tonight
your canada is pitt river in pitt
meadows bc thanks for watching donna
friesen we'll be back at the anchor desk
with you tomorrow have a great night